une dizaine de minutes de longue
respiration une série de pompes avant un
bain dans de l'eau glacée avec un bonnet
pour conserver la chaleur
ces deux têtes je les applique depuis un
an la méthode wemhoff du nom d'un
néerlandais de 58 ans surnommé l'homme
de glace après cinq minutes dans l'eau
première réaction ce qu'on ressent c'est
que c'est justement le fait qu'on soit
focalisée sur son souffle va te
permettre en fait d'apprécier
bizarrement le le côté vivifiant de
l'eau et le côté froid donc elle est
vraiment forte tu le sens le sent tout
de suite aux extrémités c'est ça le
premier point faible entre guillemets en
fait qu'on va avoir cédé extrémités que
ce soit les pieds les mains accepter le
froid et ne pas résister deux principes
enseignés avant de se lancer par cinq
instructeurs en france dont 1 dans les
yvelines les méthodes proches du yoga
peuvent être expliqués en mi journée aux
personnes en bonne santé médicale une
attitude corporelle relâcher les épaules
il ya une attitude travers la
respiration
c'est à dire si on rentre dans l'eau
sans entraînement on va être
complètement paniqué c'est à dire que le
cerveau passe en mode peurs primales on
peut par le contrôle de la respiration
reprendre le contrôle
voilà et
et calmer le jeu pour que le corps
s'adapte et laisse faire ce qui doit se
faire selon les théoriciens de cette
méthode le système immunitaire serait
renforcée suite à cette exposition froid
au total cette discipline recense près
de 150000 à 200000 adeptes à travers le
monde et notamment aux états-unis en
australie dans les yvelines seulement
une dizaine de pratiquants sont recensés